Stocker: If you've been hearing
a lot about voice technology,
artificial intelligence, and how
it's the next big thing
but you're not quite sure what
that means for you,
you're not the only one.
Whether you're a developer
trying to create
a conversational interface, a
business that wants to know
what this means for the future
of commerce,
or just a human being wondering
why in the world we need
more robots when we're trying so
hard
just to connect to each other,
you've come to the right place.
Hey, Sanched.
How's it going?
Sanched: Not too bad.
How about you?
Stocker: I'm so glad you're
here.
Sanched: Glad to be here.
Stocker: Seriously, though,
you've been doing this
for quite a while.
Sanched: It's definitely
different, and it's fairly new.
Stocker: I'm Nandini, and
welcome to this new video series
where we'll explore all things
related to voice tech
and the rich elements of human
communication
that will be the key to its
success.
Hey, Google, let's talk to
number genie.
computer voice: I'm thinking of
a number from zero to 100.
Stocker: We're looking for great
apps out there to highlight
how you're using these elements
to create your own
conversational experience.
Sanched: What you're building is
a conversation.
Stocker: What was the biggest
challenge for you?
Sanched: You realize you have so
many options.
Stocker: How do you maintain
that variability?
Sanched: So there's a lot of
opportunity here actually
for the developer to be clever.
Stocker: 'Cause cats rule the
internet.
Sanched: [laughs] Right.
Stocker: So let's talk.
That's kind of where we're
starting today is, hello, world.